desplazados a la fuerza de sus hogares
casi 4.000 venezolanos han cruzado la
frontera colombo-venezolana cerrada por
la pandemia después de los intensos
enfrentamientos en el estado de apure
entre el ejército bolivariano y
disidentes de la es guerrilla colombiana
farc atropello de todo
y los venezolanos entre los que hay más
de 1600 niños continúan llegando en
busca de seguridad a la población
colombiana de arauquita huyendo de los
bombardeos y choques que comenzaron el
fin de semana en los pueblos fronterizos
las autoridades colombianas y
organizaciones de derechos humanos han
habilitado 15 albergues y alarman de una
crisis humanitaria a mi papá se lo
llevaron en el se llama jose rico se lo
llevaron una persona inocente un
campesino de la comunidad no tiene nada
que ver con la guerra que yo
entonces nosotros queremos que nos
ayuden para que lo saquen de allá de
donde lo tienen porque no sabemos nada
en caracas el presidente de la asamblea
nacional advirtió que no permitirá que
grupos armados delincuentes del país
vecino atentan contra su país agregando
que los hechos en el resultado del
conflicto armado interno que colombiano
ha sabido responder las hostilidades
militares que se han presentado en el
vano país de venezuela donde han
involucrado población civil si la
población civil no tiene culpa
de las diferencias o los choques bélicos
que tengan las organizaciones llámese
legales o extra legales por su parte el
gobierno colombiano volvió a acusar a
venezuela de albergar a miembros de
grupos armados ilegales y reforzó la
presencia militar en la zona pese a que
ambos países que comparten 2.200
kilómetros de frontera no han tenido
relaciones diplomáticas desde inicios de